why would MIT students bring their  toenail clippings to class and how do  100 people learn how to fly airplanes in  three days could a film experience  really be more important than learning  quantum physics this is chalk radio a  podcast about inspired teaching at MIT  we have conversations with some of the  professors that make some of the most  interesting courses on campus come to  life the conversations we have with our  guests are candid quaniee serious and  personal they're the kind of  conversations you'd have if you bumped  into your favorite professor in the  infinite corridor and walk to them  across campus and that's why we're doing  this we want you to feel like you're  right here with us walking underneath  the dome experiencing the buzz that  happens when people who love science  learning and teaching all come together  to think talk and dream I hope you  listen to talk radio it's really the  closest thing to being here